Що новий президент Зеленський
хоче зробити у свої перші 100 днів на посаді?
Мабуть, чи не найбільша мрія новообраного президента -
розпустити Верховну Раду дочасно.
Адже нинішній не надто дружний парламент
Зеленському на свій бік не перетягти.
Задля розв’язання конфлікту на Донбасі
Зеленський нібито готовий до прямих переговорів з Путіним.
Але не на одинці: за круглим столом,
окрім канцлерки Німеччини Анґели Меркель
і президента Франції Еммануеля Макрона,
Зеленський хоче також бачити Великобританію і США.
З представниками так званих ЛНР і ДНР розмов не хоче.
І попросить також вийти з переговорів Віктора Медведчука.
Антикорупційні органи - НАБУ та САП Зеленський хоче перезапустити.
Набір та атестацію суддів - також перезапустити.
У СБУ та Нацполіції президент хоче забрати частину функцій
і передати їх новій Службі фінансових розслідувань.
У планах Зеленського багато законодавчих змін.
Серед першорядних -
закон про зняття недоторканності з
президента України,
народних депутатів та суддів.
А також закон про можливість імпічменту президента
та відкликання народних депутатів.
Що ЗМОЖЕ зробити новий президент?
У всіх цих ініціатив мало шансів,
якщо нинішній парламент досидить до жовтня.
Президент де-факто зможе лише підписувати
або ветувати чужі закони.
Самостійно Зеленський зможе лише призначити
нових голів Адміністрації президента, РНБО,
голови ЗСУ та Генштабу.
А от очільників Нацбанку, Міноборони, МЗС,
СБУ та ГПУ - лише через Раду.
Без Ради не змінити й прем’єр-міністра.
Берлін, Париж, Вашингтон чи Москва?
Куди здійснить свій перший закордонний візит новий президент -
поки невідомо.
А це - з досвіду попередніх років -
певною мірою вектор курсу країни
на наступні 5 років.